we turn now to black history month in a
new docu-series that reflects on the
painful history of slavery around the
world including in our own country the
four-part docu-series is called
1000 years of slavery the untold story
it premieres tonight on the smithsonian
channel a division of viacom cvs its
executive producers are two-time emmy
award-winning actor courtney b vance and
actress angela bassett the series
includes interviews with notable black
leaders like bernice king and senator
cory booker as well as historians like
the secretary of the smithsonian lonnie
bunch in this clip he talks about
resistance take a look
in some ways what slavery tells us is
that resistance is at the heart of who
they are in order to survive resistance
in large and small ways
maintaining language maintaining culture
finding ways to strike blows for freedom
lonnie bunch joins us now lonnie good
morning why do you think it's important
to reflect on
these stories of slavery and survival
more now than ever
good morning in many ways i think that
people think about how they are shaped
by their dna of their ancestors but they
forget how much they're shaped by the
historical dna and slavery in some ways
is still the last great unmentionable
it's something that people don't
understand and so the goal was to create
a series that would allow us to
understand history from a very personal
point of view understand slavery and
make sure that we can learn from this
and let that help make us better as a
nation
lani i feel like there's two types of
people people that know a little bit
about slavery and those that don't know
so what are you hoping that people learn
from this docu-series
i think what you want is people to
realize that first of all that slavery
has a long history and it's an important
institution and that slavery shaped
black life but it also shaped the lives
of all of us in some ways slavery was
one of the dominant institutions in
american life it shaped politics it
shaped foreign policy it shaped culture
so what i want people to understand the
story of black folks and their
resiliency and their struggle and how
that story is embedded in the united
states
you had a very interesting line in the
documentary lonnie you said you want to
shut down a dinner party start talking
about slavery but you said it's so
important i thought that was actually
pretty funny
and it's also very true as nate points
out it's so true but you also said it's
such an important conversation to have
because without talking about slavery
it's like looking at yourself with just
one eye
in many ways that we as americans really
are selective with the way we understand
history and i think it's important as
really president george bush said at the
opening of the museum that a great
country looks at its history confronts
its history and learns from his history
and i think that's what history is this
reservoir that will teach us who we once
were contextualize who we are and maybe
point us towards a better shared future
yeah but we've learned anything from the
last two years we've learned that
there's a good solid portion of
americans who think that looking at our
history is an exercise in guilt and they
would rather just look forward not back
i hear you making the case for it it's
an important one help us understand why
you decided to open this series with a
focus on resistance
one of the things that happened when i
was building the african-american museum
was people would come to me
african-americans and say they were
embarrassed by slavery and i wanted
people to understand that i just hope
we're as strong as our enslaved
ancestors so i wanted people to see that
folks were not broken that they found
ways to find resiliency and to find hope
yeah you said slaves often made the
impossible possible one thing that stood
out to me when we talk about slavery
it's often in the lens of economics you
said very little time is spent on the
trauma of slavery which i think is such
a such an important aspect as to who we
are and how we became who we became
in many ways that trauma has shaped us
all and so what you hope is that people
begin to understand the depths of that
trauma and really the continuing
resonance of enslavement
while it was something that legally
ended over 150 years ago its impact
stayed with us and so what we wanted was
people to just understand
that it's okay to shine a light on the
dark corners of history because we're
made better when we're in that light
lonnie as a historian i'm curious about
your uh your perspective on two new
museums approved by congress the museum
of the american latino and a
american women's history museum what
does it mean for these to be
commissioned and for the planning to
begin
well as somebody that lived through
creating a museum what i realized is by
creating the american women's history
museum and the national american latino
what you're doing is allowing the
smithsonian to create different portals
into people coming to understand what it
means to be an american these are
crucially important stories that are
worthy not just of the smithsonian but
are worthy of america and so i'm excited
about the challenge of crafting two
museums that will tell america's story
through different lenses
lonnie thank you so much docuseries like
these are necessary history untold is a
history that is at risk of being lost
thank you so much we appreciate you 1
000 years of slavery the untold story
premieres tonight on the smithsonian
channel